it's time for roses and Rosie hey you
guys bachelor in paradise oh here we go
everybody
we'd been hypnotized watch the spinning
umbrella as it tells you about how
you're going to find out about the
scandal on the premiere and then you
don't I was disappointed I would say
that I felt a storm was coming and I got
only a little trickle what's on the end
of this umbrella it looks like a torture
device
great let me torture you let me tell you
that you're going to see all about
Corinne Demario in the premiere let me
tease you for weeks of scandal
speculation only to give you pretty much
what you saw in the promo let's dive
right and everybody oh those are $40
sunglasses anyway I'm drinking out of a
full bottle of wine tonight like a dirty
pirate sailor because that's how the
bachelor in paradise premiere made me
feel it's a long time for the rose' to
get to you on suspicion of to the bottle
okay there is trouble in
erinite become aware of allegation so in
the beginning we start out with this
like media sound mashup Oh JC Thank You
JC everybody Edison he edits the videos
hi JC and he brought me a table for my
phone call the gentleman my friend is on
then that means you will get to it so
first we begin with the media talking
about the scandal and like boys Silver's
not and you know what I was here for
that that's what I wanted more of I
thought we were going to get like a
really distinct timeline of everything
and that it was going to be a lot of
cuts to black with like text on screen
explaining the decisions the producers
made that did not happen
instead we got Chris Harrison on empty
set welcome to a new season of bachelor
in paradise he's like let's start with
everything as you can see no one else is
here it's just me in these beds we
didn't even wash the sheets there
leftover things have been in them but no
one else is here on the set I'm Chris
Harrison
we know we know and then we cut to two
weeks earlier so we're going to see the
footage of before the scandal those
first like two days of filming so
everybody's getting there and here's how
I would summarize that drink every time
somebody likes bean I kind of he is
dreaming drink every time somebody likes
Raven I'm liking what she's wearing so
far all right
no i'ma leave this closer my mouth and
drink every time Iggy enthusiastically
greet someone
and now be careful of course of what
you're drinking though on roses and
Rosie we don't have a to drink per hour
minimum or whatever it is that they
ended up instituting in paradise but do
be careful and don't drive so oh one
part drink every time then Lauren talks
about a job I got a dog I love the black
and brown
I know juice wants a dog mom that is a
man in love I know you know why he's in
paradise you start the greatest
relationship of his life is dog so he
was there to find a mom for his dog
that's not a selling point Ben I hate
dogs I don't really but finish clinic
like unnervingly Mellon I feel like
they're happy gonna have to happen then
there's like a lot of sad foreshadowing
with tamari oh he's here for the right
reason welcome to paradise
he's here for a rare first chance at
redemption we all know how this ends up
Thanks I'm not rushing to find someone
I'm not going to jump on the first guy
that you know shows me a little bit of
attention and we really see how jamario
and Corinne paired up I mean this was
probably the most interesting part for
me is that we saw that jamario and
Corinne were having a real connection
they're like joking about being Angie
and Brad and that's a stretch but
they're like talking about getting
engaged and they're like being super
sweet with each other and they're both
from New Jersey I mean drink every time
it seems like they were on their way to
like a pretty cute relationship Mario
Alex Alex tomorrow
okay you've got a whistle but the
information stops there and learn how to
say now
yeah you know and Kareem was even like
her old funny soul girls cracking me up
I got a funny she is campaign jump on
panic then Amanda Stan came in and threw
some hilarious shade at her ex Josh
Marie
he was [ __ ] person and game Chris
Harrison back the ring
it smells like pizza then more Chris
Harrison alone and he's like there's not
even a crew as you can see I'm still
here alone on the set of bachelor in
paradise
no cast no crew in sight Chris who is
filming you someone filming you a crew
mm-hmm grabs a tada
thank you thank you oh another game
drink every time somebody makes out in
the premiere don't do that that would be
so dangerous
there were so many make outs on this
premiere they really tried to show a lot
of like the other love connections that
were made you know so begin the setup
the whole rest of the season and not
make it beef up a scandal and I get that
but I needed more of the scandal because
it just got confusing you know I was
confused so we go through all this and
then you know it's like everybody's
making out and suddenly it's the morning
after it's the morning after things with
Kernan jamario and I literally was like
did I have sauce pouring through the
commercials I didn't watch
did I miss something did I miss a spot
that I knew swish
where was it did I miss the more
information I'm confused
it was the morning after and Demario is
like you know this much school the other
day I must say that I feel rejuvenated
I'm on my fourth smoothie what what I
mean for who how can you drink that many
smoothies and so I'm distracted by that
but still I need to know what happened
again I was looking for like a cut to
black like a like a I don't know like
you know when a documentary like it's
like cut to black there's white text on
the screen and they're like production
has chosen not to show this footage out
of respect for all parties we learn that
and like I needed something like that an
out of respect for all parties kind of a
moment because they're trending
everything seems so happy
and you know what it was up
that's do it's just a little thing
tonight yeah yeah you can bust up yeah
look good man
now Robbie's here because again things
are happy and Robbie's hair is here and
I did kind of love how much they all
laugh about Robbie's hair Robbie just is
really like and it's teeth now the
swimsuit she brought a male the speedos
he brought drink every time you see
Robbie it's one of the swimsuit I rub my
feet at the middle I did I needed to see
the speedos well how many Robbie how
many we'll have a minute easy online
comm will answer your burning questions
he talks about hangin in no he did not
we're all just supposed to keep smiling
like Robbie like nothing's happened but
a lots happened and then this was a nice
little moment Raven went on a date with
Robbie and you know helpless and she
gave the most hilarious siskel and ebert
level review of her date with Robbie
can't go on another date with someone
who was prettier hair than me for your
skin than me and for your absently props
to Raven and then she's like not even
into Robbie she's into Ben's Orin and
she tells him he was a better kisser
than Robbie that was better
[Music]
oh my gosh drink every time Raymond
owned this premiere oh not that easy
this was cooler my head this string out
of bottle thing how most America
well Hank cooler in my head cooler in my
head
the Loren zebra story named in my bio
anyway and in my biography I cut into
black on the first page Matt goes on a
date with jasmine and I hit me really
made me like Matt I mean he was a
sweetie always but it was nice to see
like how fun he used to I like Matt
great and now Jasmine Jasmine just doing
her thing having fun great but seriously
what about Corinne and Demario stop
hypnotizing me with the fun ABC stop it
stop it stop it I want to see what her
search yeah anyway I knew they weren't
going to show us the moment but I did
need to see more moments so in like the
last five minutes of the episode
oh and Derek and Taylor hit it off great
I talked to Derek about the premiere
that interviews of a DC online comm
shameless slaw also sweetheart also
getting his do in paradise I like it
know what's up what's the deal so in the
last five minutes of the episode it's
like Karina's gonna give her rose to
Vinnie and you're like what when did
grin and Demario stop being me Angie and
Brad paradise we are confused why are
they not even like flirting still on the
second day what happened
and then production is shut down and
there are shaky camera angles and people
are confused and again it's mostly
footage we saw on the promos and then
we're T's to Tuesday tomorrow night
odd bachelor in paradise and on Tuesday
when I see production resumed again and
we're going to see that and I watch it
yes but again today want more
yes so we're out that's it that's it
I don't know was I the only one who felt
like the ages were weird like it sailor
really 23 our tailor was old 143 I don't
know you guys it was about sinking or
swimming and we stopped businesses
hogging up and really impeding my fake
eyelashes I wish that I can write here's
an idea was it almost I have a great
idea it's not going to work I was trying
to a snorkel bomb ha I love these shows
but I was this and I have to tell it
like it is so please let me know
were you guys disappointed I am
available on Instagram Twitter snapchat
and please like easy on Facebook and
subscribe to us on YouTube where we will
continue on all these journeys together
[Music]
so would you guys rather be stuck on a
desert island with Derek beam or Demario
that was a weird sort of option but I
still want to know Derrick builds a
fighter
Derrick built a fire for Taylor but Dean
you know I guess everything's is really
cute not really my type and Demario is
pretty funny so let me know have a great
night everyone stay dry can you loosen
it oh my god oh really a failure right
now I have a master space wow I can't
breathe okay that's why I'm out
[Music]